when apple went out on stage and
announced the brand new m2 macbook air
back in june i had no idea just how much
drama and controversy would be stirred
up over the next month and it's no doubt
made reviewing this laptop properly a
heck of a lot more difficult so in this
one month review i'm gonna forget that
drama ever happened and take a fresh
look at the m2 macbook air no longer
comparing its faults to other macbooks
like the previous m1 model or the 14
inch macbook pro and i'll instead focus
on the laptop itself and what i've
learned about it and enjoyed over the
past month so let's get started
even though it's already been one month
since this new m2 macbook air has been
in our office i'm still blown away every
time i pick it up because it's just so
incredibly thin and light especially if
you have the display open and you're
holding the bottom portion seriously
what apple achieved in terms of design
is absolutely incredible being thinner
than the previous macbook air especially
on the hinge side and the next point
that really stands out to me is the
incredible display with the new modern
design with those thin bezels all the
way around no longer making it feel like
you're holding an old device and the
biggest benefit is that apple finally
souped up this display to match the rest
of their macbook lineup bringing the
brightness up to a pleasant 500 nits and
adding support for more colors i've
gotta say this thing feels fresh and i
absolutely love the rounded corners on
the display which makes it look and feel
like a newer ipad design and the crazy
thing is that the notch at the top has
grown on me and to my surprise i
actually prefer the notch look because
it makes it stand out from the laptop
crowd now i know you're gonna call me
crazy for even mentioning that but the
notch has subconsciously just
disappeared when using it day to day i
don't even realize it's there kind of
like how everyone can technically see
their nose at all times but your mind
just blocks it out for you it's kind of
the same effect on the m2 macbook air
especially since it only takes up the
space that's used by the menu bar and
disappears completely when in full
screen mode and of course the biggest
benefit of all from that notch is the
1080p webcam that not only matches the
higher end 14 and 16 inch macbook pros
but it looks slightly better because of
the updated image signal processor and
other optimizations i also like how
apple is so confident in their branding
an image that they don't even need this
laptop to say macbook air anywhere on
the device not even on the bottom it's
so iconic that you can't mistake it for
any other laptop because no other
company could achieve this thin design
and performance combo in a laptop kind
of like no other company can achieve the
reliability and speed of our sponsor
nordvpn which is essentially a service
that encrypts your internet traffic on
every major platform to protect your
precious internet browsing data and your
ip address with just one click or even
zero clicks if you choose the auto
connect option and not only that but
while you're enjoying safe and private
browsing nord's threat protection
feature is blocking intrusive ads web
trackers and malicious malware and as a
bonus nord allows you to create an
encrypted connection from another
country to unlock content like movies
shows and games that aren't available in
the country you're living in seriously
some people get nordvpn just for that
feature alone and it's also the best vpn
out there thanks to having over 5400
servers in 59 countries which is why
it's also the fastest vpn out there so
protect your internet browsing today
with nordvpn by clicking the link below
to save on a north vpn plan with a 30
day money back guarantee now getting
back to the macbook air i absolutely
love the mac safe 3 charging feature
especially since it supports fast
charging and it comes with a little
indicator light so you know if the
battery is full even from across the
room it's literally the best way to
charge a laptop ever invented requiring
only one hand to attach or detach
compared to previous usbc only macbooks
which you have to hold down with your
other hand to plug in the cable and the
other obvious benefit is that both of
the thunderbolt ports are now freed up
and available for accessories at any
time instead of being used up by the
charging cable like before so in terms
of design portability and functionality
the m2 macbook air is a huge step up but
what about the actual performance and
reliability well for regular users who
spend most of their time doing common
things like browsing the web the m2
macbook air is literally the best laptop
in the business because of its very high
single core performance as well as all
the software optimizations it achieves
the highest speedometer web browsing
benchmark score we've ever seen on any
computer which means that you won't find
any other laptop that'll feel as snappy
as this one while browsing the web and
doing basic stuff like using apps and
watching media content now while i am a
bit disappointed in the speaker quality
because of apple's choice to relocate
the speaker grills to the inside of the
hinge leading to a sound stage that
isn't as wide as before they still beat
out pretty much every other laptop out
there and there is no doubt that after
one month i'm still upset at apple for
removing one of the nand chips on the
base m2 macbook air compared to the
previous model leading to slower file
transfer speeds and worse virtual memory
swap performance but if you're a common
user that's only going to be doing large
file transfers and heavy multitasking
with productivity apps every once in a
while it probably won't be a big deal
for you but what if you were thinking of
buying the base empty macbook air
instead of a higher end macbook pro to
get some productivity work done while
multitasking like most people do with
browsing the web you likely will run
into slower performance than expected
which the previous base m1 model didn't
have an issue with at all now there is
an easy fix to this problem and that is
to upgrade this storage to at least 512
gigs which comes with two nand chips but
that also means that this now becomes a
1400 laptop in order to unlock excellent
multitasking performance and that's kind
of upsetting because the m1 model was
known to offer killer performance at the
base 1 000 price and you're simply not
getting that value anymore with the new
m2 macbook air but if we assume you're a
more common user that doesn't do
productivity work all the time you're
likely going to be just fine unless you
like to open dozens of web browsing tabs
without closing them and even though we
experienced some really heavy thermal
throttling of performance due to the
inadequate fanless cooling system it was
only a serious issue when doing very
heavy work which most common people
likely won't be doing that much of and
the nice thing is that we were able to
fix those issues with a thermal pad mod
which we showed off in a video for only
15 dollars greatly improving the
performance and we even took it a step
further by adding a laptop cooling stand
which took those gains much further
getting rid of the heat soaking so if
you're interested in doing that yourself
we'll leave those links down below but
for the average user you likely won't
experience the overheating and in that
case the completely fanless design is
awesome for never having to hear fan
noise again as well as keeping the
internals dust free for many years and
as for performance without multitasking
even the base model was faster in terms
of the most common 4k hevc video editing
compared to the 14-inch macbook pro
because it comes with new encoders and
decoders which take the load off of the
cpu so it's a great sweet spot for that
type of work as well as shorter
programming and photo editing tasks and
as far as the battery life the m2
macbook air is great even better than
the m1 model and because the m2 chip now
comes with four efficiency cores that
are faster than before you can now get
an absolutely insane 15 hours of battery
life while using low power mode without
sacrificing snappy performance so you
can leave it on all the time if you'd
like to so with that said if you look at
the m2 macbook air from a more common
average user perspective it's an
absolutely killer laptop especially to
the windows competition with my biggest
gripe being the increased price while
getting downgraded ssd performance but
if you can look past that i would
definitely recommend the m2 air
especially for those who care more about
getting a modern and fresh macbook for
years to come compared to saving a few
hundred dollars and getting the older m1
macbook air design which you can find
for as little as 850 bucks on amazon and
if you disagree with my take on all of
this let me know down in the comment
section below but if you enjoyed this
one month review of the m2 macbook air
click the circle button to subscribe for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]